so what this Tim Farriss do at 2:00 in
the morning
besides drink Portuguese white wine and
watch The Bourne Identity for the 157th
time he does pendrick's which is what he
does all the time as his own fidget so
enough is talking in third person let's
check out some pendrick's so we're gonna
do these roughly in order difficulty but
they may be slightly out of order all
right so this is called the helicopter
pretty obvious I'm just gonna give you a
little showcase of things to come first
so you can get a pretty good idea of
what's possible just by looking at that
so helicopter is so named because of the
the motion just like that and I
recommend you use a Bic because it's
it's relatively well balanced and the
right diameter like it's what we're
doing here is pushing this down so that
the thumb the middle finger is at the
very centre of the pen in the back and
the thumb is about one bum width away
from the center on top all right the top
of the thumb meaning the part that's
parallel to the ground there is going to
be parallel to the ground and here I'm
pushing the pen into both my index and
middle finger and then I'm essentially
snapping these two and it spins across
the back of my thumb like so and you can
do that all day long and that's probably
the most common that you'll see in Japan
and Taiwan and the really good kids will
do it one way and then knock it back the
other way I can't do that all right so
the drummer is so named because you'll
see guys like Tommy Lee do that all
right now if you look at it from that
angle it looks like it's going up and
down and it looks very cool if you look
at it from the front it's actually just
that type of motion so really what I'm
doing is
moving the top two fingers back and
forth as this spins right in front of
the first knuckle like so and the way
you that's been started is I'm pulling
down with my index finger so the middle
finger is basically braced pushing down
with the top finger and then I'm
catching the back of the pen in this
little web and then as soon as I pull
this back it gets that initial spin and
then you keep it going with these two
fingers looks pretty cool all right then
we have suppose what I would call the
pincher and the reason I'm gonna call
that none of these things have names as
far as I know looks like that and the
reason I call it the pincher it's very
hard to see what this motion is this is
actually the first one I learned but one
of the hardest is it's the same motion
that I'm using to get that Tommy Lee
spin started but it's in between my
middle of my ring finger and as it
caught as it flips through I'm gonna
catch it in between my index and my ring
finger so it looks like that and then it
swings behind and I catch it back in
this position so it looks like this like
that very slowly okay it looks like
faster that makes sense
okay and you can either push down here
or you can do it on the thumb itself and
that's what it looks like and when you
get better at it you can do it from
different positions you can start here
for example up like that and then go up
or you can even it's a little hard to do
so looking through the camera so I just
jumped I just skipped these two fingers
and went from here to here all right so
you can get tricky with it
all right the the wheel was what I'll
call this one here it's one of it one of
the easier ones okay and then you can
mix it all together really all you're
doing is I'm pushing off of the the
thumb here between these two fingers and
it's pulling it's doing it a straight
circle through like that and you end up
in this somewhat awkward position then
you can segue into a different move so
it looks like that we'll just call that
the wheel that's probably the easiest
you'll see that I'm just pushing it down
and then this very familiar pushing with
the middle finger pretty similar to how
we started the last move but instead of
going in a circle like that we're going
in a we're pushing down on the top of
the thumbs it's further extended on the
finger tips coming straight back like a
wheel alright and then the last one that
we'll have is what I'll call the flip
and pretty self-explanatory looks like
that
no oh now that sound you just heard you
will hear thousands and thousands of
times oh all right well so much for
ending with a flourish but it it looks
like that and the better you get you can
actually keep your hand flat on a table
and flip it and catch it without moving
your hand at all like that
alright so they'll be a flip the way you
do that again the same motion but you're
going to be flicking out with your with
your ring finger do you have the
extension so it goes away from your hand
it's going to rotate it fully and it's
going to land right here in the writing
position like that alright and then you
put it all together you can do all sorts
of fancy stuff so I could do a wheel to
be pincer to helicopter you shoulda
tommylee and so forth and so on you just
will get to the point where you'll do
this while reading a newspaper and it'll
drive everybody absolutely apeshit
so have fun if you don't have OCD
already this will give it to you signing
off